Right now, we have material sliding
through material on the same elevation,
which is something the spec frowns upon.
What we'd like to do is
something more like this.
As you can see, the app bar gains
in elevation, casts a shadow,
when the content slides under.
Fortunately, we have a callback for
when the RecyclerView is scrolling.
I just realized there might be a small
percentage of you that would feel
intellectually compromised if you
didn't get to implement this effect.
This is your chance to
pause the video and
attempt to do it yourself
before I show you the answer.
Okay, last chance, and here goes.
Here's how I did this.
Inside of onCreateView,
right after our parallax stuff,
I checked to see we have an app bar.
If we have one,
I start by setting its elevation to 0.
I then I add an OnScrollListener here.
And whenever we scroll it we check
the vertical offset of the RecyclerView.
If it's zero then we know
we're not underscrolled and
we set the app bar elevation to zero.
Otherwise, we're underscrolled and we
actually set it to its TargetElevation,
which is something that app
bars do that's kind of cool.
And with that,
we get this nice underscrolling effect.
It's a little hard to see
on the tablet perhaps, but
there's actually a little shadow
there you can see that's being cast.
It's a subtle detail, but once again,
I always say when we're doing these
final steps, it's that last 10% that
really makes an enormous difference.
And sometimes, it's the last 1%.